welcome to this video playing Homer
Simpson that's whom I have a second name
like whom James Simpson or something I
don't know okay the sloth okay it's
going six other side like Quincy to
let's see what setup is going for well
known inaccurate is f5 but he didn't go
for that and this smart transposed to
various Queens gambit declines yeah like
this with Knight c3 possibly coming he's
played the very early c6 here in this
Queens gambit structure and interesting
I can take or play Bishop a form ok
guess take
maybe some aiming for f5 now nope yeah
he's some setting up something like
slightly inferior version of the lusca
defense of the Queens gambit declined I
don't want to do the temple okay maybe
some useful look move to d1 because very
often at the end the D file will open
let's see him yeah probably if he goes
yeah here I thought I could take but
yeah I understand he's relatively
quickly relatively quickly there on the
C file still I'd like to take the seems
more testing then the other
continuations maybe Quincy 7 is actually
I'm aware this is in fact good
preventing Bishop d7 and if he goes
Queen d8 I have queen d 6 or look see
one both both look attractive Roxy one
though rights it's okay you can probably
untangle themselves somehow but it's not
a big issue I still should still be
better I cannot easily move cannot
easily move any of his pieces maybe you
can consider night f8 a 97 to f6 maybe I
also should be 52 c 6 as a possible a
possible threat you know that's a very
nice position really interesting very
interesting approach C going for Bishop
a six maybe maybe also for night a six
okay okay i want a 5 b 52 further
further limit is his options yeah here i
have an interesting choice i can play i
can just capture and kinky tool which
should be should be slightly better but
i can also play Lucas III and just send
him back yeah this is more precise
you should be seven then be five
yeah I don't really know what blacks
movers here I could have taken c8 Bishop
is six but then it's got Roxy one maybe
this is not isn't so great and now I can
prove I can prepare that actually with
with this smooth and that's good anyway
I guess now I'm threatening really rook
c8 bish of a six okay so um let's see
just be sure to miss Bishop here I guess
and then look see one yeah still still
not much that you can do b5 Roxy seven
rocks e7 b7 I wonder maybe I should have
gone Bishop d3 and then you form my
night is not playing that's so that's a
problem I should have gone to 2d three
probably probably I should have done
that
IDC five now to fight for central
squares you cannot take Bishop takes
loses material in the corner I'm going
to play you five to fight for more space
and maybe the e5 square for the night
it's a really bad position are still for
black
in the situation with e 5 f-5 I can
expand on the kingside further 3g 3h for
Knight to f4 okay doing that so the
night over to f4 yeah what g5 is not a
move ready let's see if there any way to
how to improve this best the night
worship tonight go yeah bb5 is not
really helping yeah maybe still just
here prevent g5 and come with G form he
cannot really move anything in any case
and the next step is the Knight to f4
druke p7700 saw some getting close to a
stalemate situation
a seven is also just hanging so yeah
time warning b5 first i don't know i can
i can really just take there is
absolutely nothing you can do 96 I just
go to be seven and then be six ponies
are is a gonner look to see five for the
next pin
yes was designed just a very bad
position out of the opening maybe I
could have taken c8 this could solve
this a bit to be too late yeah b6 is
really a move that I really would have
think twice about before I play that I
mean black also has this still the
counter player deal with e5 like rook e8
intending to take on c4 and play you
five something like something like this
yeah just to show now we five is
probably something like this insert this
and then go if I've probably I'm better
because of Rube DEA agents I think it's
not really good here yeah maybe it needs
more preparation or taking and then be
six it's similar to the lusca just a bit
inferior this way i don't know i mean i
really get this this commanding position
now King YouTube looks normal that
before is also good yeah well this this
I don't know it can be I here here and I
a CSS check of course Arkansas may be
here yeah okay but I keep an advantage
in any case here Bishop d3 is stronger
it really is I was thinking that we
should be three runs into e 584 at some
stage but it never gets there there
should be three is slightly better but
here this is already a very sorry state
of like cannot cannot do anything active
this is gradually pushed back no I guess
you should take but it's not it's not a
difference really it's I guess it's
strategically lost in any case yeah now
this is a perfect position everything's
on dark squares with a light squared
Bishop and black is basically in zoom so
on
with equal material here the computer
gives plus 7 yeah b7 gym yeah just just
wins the house yeah b6 is probably in a
strategical send some very very bad
charlie he can also i mean you can also
try and the spirit of the luscombe to
take it should takes then be six with v
should be seven and later c5 it's
slightly inferior as mentioned a couple
of times to the lusca because at least
age six is not in things like that but
still probably and you should do that
the game certainty was worse okay thanks
for watching